climate change and conflicts around the
world especially in ukraine are
threatening food security globally but
the problem is particularly difficult in
africa where a record number of people
are facing hunger now dw is blaise eong
mess up with a businessman and farmer
aiming to promote smart agriculture in
the village of dibombari in cameroon
10 years ago roland for munda returned
to cameroon from the u.s to start
greenhouse farming
it's a method of agriculture that
remains new in cameroon
rolanda has more than 100 greenhouse
farms across the country
year-round he cultivates crops that are
either scarce in the market or were
traditionally available only in certain
seasons
we grow based on what the market demands
we grow bell peppers because prior to us
doing bell peppers they were actually
been imported so we've actually been
able to substitute the importation of
bell peppers into the country one of the
things we've been able to do is to show
to the cameroonians that listen the
things that are normally been imported
or grown abroad could also be grown here
the ukrainian war thousands of
kilometers away has triggered a price
cycle food in cameroon like the rest of
the continent
soaring food prices are making it hard
for many families to afford a complete
meal
the stems are good you can carry on for
roland thinks african farmers can learn
from the crisis and better is
agricultural output by changing how
farming is done
with the russian crisis it is a curse
and a blessing at the same time and i
believe that it actually reminds us of
the need of you know industrialized or i
say precision agriculture and we talk
about precision agriculture greenhouse
farming sits at the very core of that
in a bit to share its knowledge and
contribute to food security across
cameroon roland is now offering classes
to teach young people how to set up
greenhouse farms
like this
tegum sonita 29 is currently among
dozens of young people under roland's
year-long mentorship
she's been here for six months learning
all it takes to set up and run a
greenhouse farm
before coming here i didn't have
any clue maybe i had just the basic
knowledge about farming but i do not
have the real knowledge about greenhouse
so i was just delighted when i saw it on
facebook
roland harvest crops every week from his
farms across cameroon
this greenhouse alone has about 3 000
plants of cherry tomatoes and bell pepe
160 kilograms of bell pepper is being
harvested today
there are local traders already waiting
for the produce
one of them is this supermarket in dwala
magazine
roland is meeting with the manager this
afternoon
the management prioritizes roland's
clubs over their imported competitors
they buy bell peppers and tomatoes from
him
there are many reasons why we work with
local producers first it's because of
the freshness of the crops that's
because the crops are grown nearby
the second reason is due to the cost
it's expensive to import these kinds of
goods so buying them locally provides an
affordable option for our clients
roland is pushing for sustainable and
organic food cultivation
with water saving techniques and
efficient land use
his smart innovation could help in
transforming cameron's agriculture
forever
and my next guest you already saw in
that report roland formandam and sonita
font welcome to the both of you to dw
news africa roland
you first this is an innovative business
model in many ways tell us about your
vision for greenhouse ventures and what
you've achieved since you started in
2014
our vision since inception
was being able to introduce a new model
of agriculture a model that we believe
that would attract and retain the use a
model that we believe would increase
food production and the model would
believe that it would go a long way to
stabilize market prices and go and
actually make sure that we're able to uh
upgrade our methods of agriculture from
moving from a first generation or
traditional agriculture to a more modern
or second generation agriculture
agriculture has taken the backseat in
africa for too long and we believe that
by making such uh changes we should be
able to bring agriculture at the
forefront of development another aspect
is the fact that we've been able to uh
uh find many ways to attract or make
agriculture so sexy that many youths
today feel part of being part of this
agricultural revolution uh for me
personally i think that it is a huge
remark to our success uh because for so
long the youth have not wanted to get
involved in agriculture and that is a
big problem
yes so sunita i'll come to you now
because you are one of those young
people that roland would be talking
about you have been
learning the trade you've been growing
vegetables how's it been going
well it has been
an amazing experience given the fact
that when coming here i had no idea what
it was all about but for the past six
months that i've been here i've had a
great time because i'm learning every
day and
it is something worth what it's so i
think it's it's good so anita what are
your hopes for the future um will you be
working on a farm do you want to set up
one of your own what tell us about what
do you want to do
definitely i want to set up one of them
for myself because you know agriculture
is evolving every day and as we are
doing sustainable agriculture
we don't have a room for
for
weight that's the production is
continuous
so i really want to have one of my own
in the future
roland
training people to use
greenhouses is is a central part of your
project can you just tell us a little
bit more about that specifically
um today we are very very proud because
one we are the first and only
greenhouse training institution in the
country and of course uh with that we've
been able to attract so many youths
also our training platforms today we'll
train over a thousand of them we have
the likes of people like sonata uh who
came in as a student today she's
actually a farm manager and our goal is
that someday she can actually go on to
set up our own farm and we all hope to
have uh engage them in a franchise
system wherein we would guarantee uh
buybacks for any production that they do
have but we also continue to monitor and
evaluate their progress to make sure
that they are succeeding in the domain
sunita i want to come back to you
because you talked a little bit about
this but how is
smart sustainable agriculture different
uh to some of the traditional practices
in cameroon
well the sustainable is different
because the production is continuous it
is consistent there is no season that we
don't produce but with the traditional
agriculture you know without the rain
you can't reduce so there is that's
that a stumbling block of climate change
but in the greenhouse everything is
continuous
yeah and uh incredible stuff that you
guys are doing out there in cameroon
it's great to have you both in the
program so uh sonita fon and roland uh
fourmandom thank you so much for being
on the program today appreciate it guys
thank you very much